Aquí tenemos una pintura de René Descartes
una de las mentes más brillantes,
tanto en matemáticas como en filosofía
porque esto era algo bastante común, que grandes filósofos también eran grandes matemáticos
y viceversa, de alguna manera era
contemporáneo de Galileo...
era 32 años menor que Galileo aunque murió poquito después que Galileo, este cuate murió joven
Galileo ya era mayor de 70 años, mientras que Descartes murió a tan solo 54 años de edad.
Descartes es más conocido en la cultura popular por esta cita que tenemos aquí:
una cita filosófica "pienso luego existo",
pero también quería mostrarte y esto
no tiene que ver con álgebra,
pero es una cita muy precisa quizás la menos
conocida de sus citas...
esta que tenemos aquí, y yo pienso que es muy práctica y te hace darte cuenta que estas grandes mentes,
estos pilares de la filosofía las matemáticas al final de cuentas eran simples seres humanos,
y dice: "Tan solo sigue intentando, tan solo sigue intentando, incurrí en todos los errores posibles...
simplemente seguí intentando"
pienso que este es un gran consejo para la vida.
Ahora, él hizo muchas cosas en filosofía y matemáticas
pero la razón por la cual lo estoy incluyendo aquí en esta fundamentación del álgebra que estamos haciendo
es que él es el responsable directo de ese fuerte vínculo que se establece entre el álgebra y la geometría.
Aquí tenemos de nueva cuenta la palabra álgebra,
hemos platicado acerca de ella tenemos ecuaciones que se establecen con símbolos...
símbolos que básicamente toman valores.
Si tenemos por ejemplo algo como "y" igual a "2x" menos 1 esto establece una relación
entre cualquier cosa que represente "x" y cualquier cosa que represente "y" podemos de hecho...
construir una tabla aquí, tomar valores de "x" y ver cuáles son los valores de "y" correspondientes
podría tomar valores aleatorios de "x"
y calcular cuál es el valor de "y"
pero va a tomar valores que son relativamente simples y comunes, para que las matemáticas no se compliquen.
Así por ejemplo si "x" es igual a -2
"y" es igual a 2 por -2 menos 1
2 por -2 -1 y esto es igual,
2 por - 2 es -4, -1 es igual a -5
Tomemos ahora "x" igual a -1
"y" va ser igual a 2 por -1... -1
2 por -1 = -2  y -1 esto es igual a -3
si "x" es igual a 0 "y" es igual a 2 por 0 menos 1,
2 por 0 es 0, -1 esto es igual a -1
Voy a hacer un par más,
si "x" es igual a 1, y puedo tomar
cualesquiera valores aquí
puedo ver qué pasa si "x" es igual a
menos la raíz cuadrada de 2
o qué pasa si "x" es igual a -5/2 ó 6 séptimos
sin embargo, estoy tomando estos valores
que facilitan el cálculo del valor de "y"
entonces cuando "x" es igual a 1
"y" va a ser igual a 2 por 1 menos 1
esto es igual, 2 por 1 = 2 menos 1 es igual a 1
voy a hacer un último valor, voy a hacerlo en otro color
aquí tenemos el púrpura que no usado aún, entonces cuando "x" es igual a 2 "y" va a ser igual a 2 por 2
menos 1
2 por 2 es igual a 4 menos 1 esto es igual a 3
suficiente, por así decirlo saque
muestras de esta relación
por un lado aquí se describe una relación general entre una variable "y" y una variable "x"
y simplemente la hice más concreta dije, ok si "x" es una de estas variables para cada uno de los valores de "x"
¿cuál sería el valor correspondiente de "y"?
y Descartes se dio cuenta que podías visualizar esto...
por un lado puedes visualizar estos puntos individuales
y eso te va a ayudar en general a
visualizar esta relación.
Básicamente lo que hizo fue establecer un puente entre el mundo abstracto del álgebra simbólica
y el mundo de la geometría que tiene que ver con formas, dimensiones y ángulos.
Entonces aquí tenemos la palabra geometría
y obviamente hay gente en la historia quizás mucha gente cuya historia se ha olvidado
gente que pudo haber incursionado en esto,
pero antes de Descartes...
la visión general que se tenía de la geometría
era la de la geometría euclidiana,
la cual básicamente es la geometría que estudiaste en las clases de geometría de secundaria y preparatoria,
es esa geometría que estudia las relaciones entre triángulos y sus ángulos...
las relaciones que se encuentran
entre los círculos y sus radios
y aquellas que se establecen entre los triángulos inscritos en círculos
ya profundizaremos sobre esto en la lista de geometría.
Así que Descartes dijo, bueno yo creo que puedo representar esto visualmente
de la misma manera que Euclides estudió estos triángulos  y estos círculos...
y se dijo, que tal si consideramos un pedazo de papel
pensemos en dos dimensiones...
ese pedazo de papel puedes considerarlo como una sección de dos dimensiones,
las llamamos dos dimensiones porque tenemos la dirección que va de arriba hacia abajo...
déjame hacerlo en azul, estamos tratando de visualizar cosas así es que usar el color de la geometría
entonces es la dimensión que va de arriba hacia abajo...
y también tenemos la dimensión
que va de izquierda a derecha
por eso lo llamamos el plano bidimensional,
si estuviéramos usando tres dimensiones tendríamos la dimensión que va de adentro hacia afuera.
Es muy fácil trabajar en dos dimensiones en una pantalla, pues la pantalla es bidimensional
y se dijo bien aquí tenemos dos variables
que tienen esta relación
¿por qué no asociamos cada una de estas variables con cada una de las dimensiones aquí?
y por convención hagamos esta la variable "y"
que realmente en la variable dependiente, la manera como la construimos depende de lo que es "x"
pongamos entonces ese en el eje vertical y pongamos nuestra variable independiente,
aquella en la cual tomamos valores aleatorios
para obtener el valor de "y"
pongamos está en el eje horizontal,
de hecho fue Descartes quien propuso la
convención de usar "x" "y"
y como veremos posteriormente "z" propuso esto para el álgebra para designar las incógnitas...
o las variables que estamos manipulando
y se dijo, si lo vemos de esta manera si numeramos estas dimensiones
así tomemos entonces en la dirección "x"
-3
Luego aquí tenemos
-2
-1
0,
simplemente estoy enumerando la dirección "x"  la que va de izquierda a derecha
éste es entonces 1, éste es 2
éste es 3,
lo mismo vamos a hacer para la dirección "y"
aquí tenemos
-5
-4
- 3
de hecho, déjame hacerlo más claro
déjame borrarle aquí un poco, lo voy a borrar para que podamos extendernos y así podamos llegar hasta el -5
sin que se vea muy desordenado, bajemos todo esto para poder numerarlo
entonces tenemos 1, 2,
aquí tenemos -1
-2
y estas son simplemente convenciones, podemos poner el eje "x" aquí el "y" aquí
y tomar los positivos del lado izquierdo los
negativos del lado derecho
en fin, son convenciones desde la época de Descartes
sigamos - 3, -4, -5...
él dijo bueno, yo creo que pueda asociar
cada pareja de valores
con un punto en el plano bidimensional
puedo tomar la coordenada en "x" el valor de "x" por ejemplo el valor de -2
es -2 hacia la izquierda en este eje que va de izquierda a derecha es hacia la izquierda pues es negativo
y está asociado con -5, -5 hacia abajo en el eje vertical decimos que el valor de "y" es -5
así es que si vamos 2 hacia la izquierda y 5 abajo
obtenemos este punto de aquí,  así que lo que dijo...
estos dos valores de -2 y -5 los puedo asociar con este punto aquí en el plano bidimensional
así que decimos, este punto de aquí tiene las coordenadas que me indican cómo encontrar
el punto -2, -5
estas coordenadas son conocidas como coordenadas cartesianas en honor precisamente a René Descartes
porque fue él quien las introdujo...
él tuvo la idea de asociar estas relaciones con puntos en un plano coordenado,
y entonces dijo, hagamos otra relación,
aquí tenemos otra relación, cuando "x" es igual a -1
cuando "x" es igual a -1 "y" es igual a -3
así que "x" es -1 "y" -3 es este punto de aquí y la convención es cuando escribe las coordenadas...
primero escribes la coordenada en "x" y luego la coordenada en "y" eso es lo convenido
-1, -3 el punto que tenemos aquí
y luego tenemos el punto cuando "x" vale 0 y "y" vale -1
cuando "x" vale 0 aquí lo tenemos, significa que no te mueves ni a la izquierda ni a la derecha
"y" es -1, uno hacia abajo aquí tenemos el punto 0, -1
ahí tenemos este punto
y así seguimos el punto 1,1
1 para "x", 1 para "y" aquí lo tenemos
el punto 2, 3
2 para "x" 3 para "y"
de hecho déjame hacerlo en el mismo color púrpura,
es el punto 2 ,3
aquí lo voy a poner también en naranja el punto 1, 1
esto ya es estupendo en sí, lo que hice básicamente fue tomar valores arbitrarios de "x"
pero lo que él se dio cuenta es que si tú tomas valores,
otros valores de "x" si tomas valores de "x" entre estos que ya tomé al final de cuentas tendrás
la gráfica de una recta así que si tú pudieras tomar todos los valores posibles de "x"
terminarías con la gráfica de una recta, parecida a ésta la gráfica de una recta
como ésta que tenemos aquí y cualquier relación si tú tomas cualquier "x" y encuentras la "y" correspondiente
representa en realidad un punto sobre esta línea
otra manera de ver esto es que cualquier
punto sobre esta recta
representa una solución a esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí.
Así si tenemos este punto de aquí en el cual parece que "x" es uno y medio, "y" es igual a 2
déjame escribir eso
1.5, 2
esa es una solución de esta ecuación
cuando "x" es 1.5,  2 por 1.5 es 3 menos 1 es 2,
vemos que se cumple la ecuación
así de repente,
él fue capaz de construir un puente sobre este hueco
estableciendo la relación entre álgebra y geometría
podemos ahora visualizar
todas las parejas de "x" "y" que satisfacen
esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí, así que él es el responsable
de hacer este puente
y es por eso que las coordenadas que usamos para especificar estos puntos
se llaman coordenadas cartesianas
y como veremos el primer tipo de ecuaciones que se estudian son ecuaciones como estas
que en un curso tradicional de álgebra se llaman ecuaciones lineales...
ecuaciones lineales...
y podrías pensar, bueno,
veo que esto es una ecuación "y" igual a algo con "x"
¿pero qué tiene esto de lineal?
¿que es lo que hace que se vean como una línea?
para darse cuenta ¿por qué es lineal?
Tienes que dar el brinco que dio René Descartes, porque si gráficas esto usando coordenadas cartesianas
sobre un plano euclidiano vas a obtener una línea recta y próximamente verás que existen otro tipo de ecuaciones
donde no tienes una línea recta obtienes una curva
o figuras locas y extrañas